DOUG MARCAIDA: You ready?
RITA: Hai.
It will--
The sodegarami.
Holy geez.
Oh, my God.
DOUG MARCAIDA: One of the most
intimidating and versatile
Japanese pole weapons,
the sodegarami,
was part of the key
arsenal for samurai police
during the 17th century.
Featuring lethal
spikes and hooks,
police were able to
capture violent offenders
from the distance
by using the weapon
to latch onto the suspects,
stopping them in their tracks.
Although primarily
used in defense,
the sharp spikes along
with the spiked bud cap
made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat.
Today, the sodegarami's
devastating use
can be seen in the HBO
television series, "Westworld."
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your sodegarami will do,
I will take your
weapons, and stab,
and try to snag this
ballistics dummy.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Hai.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, let's do this.
[music playing]
All right.
All right, Rita, sorry
about your sodegarami.
The tongs you have
here penetrates.
The hook you have here
will rip this person apart,
and more importantly,
your weapon will kill.
All right, Justin, your turn.
Are you ready to have fun?
JUSTIN: Yes, sir.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Justin,
the times you have here,
it's more of a stabbing kind
rather than a grabbing.
This is a grabbing weapon, but
that hook does grab onto that.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
DAVID LAIN BAKER: All
right, bladesmiths,
it's time for the strength test,
the dreaded ice block chop.
Remember, this is not
about what these weapons do
to the ice blocks,
but what those ice
blocks do to your weapons.
And, Rita, you're up first.
You get points for theme.
I mean, are you ready?
It doesn't matter, right?
No, it doesn't matter.
[music playing]
DAVID LAIN BAKER:
All right, Rita,
you've got a little bit more of
a bend in this one tong here,
but everything else is pretty
much the way it was going in.
It definitely held
up, did its job.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Justin, your turn.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
DAVID LAIN BAKER: All right, so
you survived the strength test.
This is a very strong,
well-built head for this,
but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching.
I mean, I'm not
sure how effective
it would be at
snagging the opponent,
but it's a devastator.
It certainly did the job.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness test,
the sandman pierce and capture.
To test its sharpness,
I will take your weapon.
Pierce and try to
control this sandman.
Rita, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Yeah.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Rita, the points
you have on your tongs
here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that, but
doesn't slice on the way out
or capture as well as it should.
Your hook over here did its job.
Overall, it will
cut and control.
All right, Justin, your turn.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
That's not good.
WIL WILLIS: He pulled
it out of the socket.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well,
Justin, we have a problem.
Yes, sir.
This wasn't pinned, was it?
No.
DOUG MARCAIDA: The impact from
all these tests loosened it up,
and, of course, it came off.
Justin, you brought in a
beautifully crafted weapon.
However, you've suffered
a catastrophic failure
in our final test, and
unfortunately, you cannot be
our "Forged in Fire" champion.
Congratulations, Rita.
Thank you.
Awesome.
I come in on "Forged in Fire."
I put my all into it, and I
feel like I made a good weapon.
But it just came up
short on a little bit
of the fit and finish, and other
than that, I'm happy with it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Rita,
congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
How do you feel right now?
I just--
DOUG MARCAIDA: Come on
forward and shake our hands.
Good job.
It's been a very
positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do
something amazing, like this.
I hope this will help me
become an inspiration to kids.
Because I can say, look,
if you see something,
and you want to try
it, give it a try.
Hey, [inaudible]
Your scout leader
is the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I'm bringing it home.
We should have a
group hug, please.
Thank you, you guys.
Oh, my God.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: The Japanese ono.
Oh, yes, and here
to tell you more
about it, historic
weapons recreation
specialist, David Baker.
DAVID LAIN BAKER:
The Japanese ono
was a long, battle ax used
by the samurai warriors
during the 17th century.
Measuring nearly six feet
long, these intimidating pole
axes were used to
destroy barricades
and smash opponent's armor.
After becoming futile
Japan's official police force
during the Edo
period, the samurai
used their ono to keep the
peace, which they accomplished
for over 250 years.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
It's time to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your onos will do.
To find out, we'll
take your weapon
and deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Let's see if your onos
can be an, oh, yes.
Logan, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
LOGAN: Yes, sir.
Coming into testing,
my biggest fear
is that the shaft's
going to break,
but I made this ono for battle.
It is ready to kill.
[music playing]
Oh, Logan, this
is a lot of fun.
The damage that you did
with your design over here
for every chop,
using this digs in.
On the way out, it guts you.
It pretty much opened everything
and crushed everything
in its path.
More importantly, your ono
is an, oh, yes, it will kill.
Thank you.
Keaton, your turn.
Are you ready?
KEATON: Oh, yeah.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Keaton, let's
talk about your ono here.
At first, when I picked it up, I
was like, oh wow, that's light.
But then, when I wielded
it, I was like, oh yes.
This thing stayed on.
It's solid.
Your edges, they're sharp, and
that's why it dug in very deep.
Overall, sir, your
ono was an, oh, yes.
It will kill.
Thank you.
HOST: Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test,
bamboo wall chop.
Now, to push your
onos to the limit,
I'm going to beat
them repeatedly
against a strong,
thick, springy bamboo.
Now, again, it's not what
your onos do to the wall.
It's what the wall
does to your onos.
Logan, how are you feeling?
Good.
I feel good too.
Let's get to it.
[music playing]
All right, Logan, good job.
Your edge is still good.
Everything's still tight.
It's heavy.
The wrap makes it
a little difficult
to slide down during the chop,
but everything's still tight.
It's sharp.
It did a lot to that.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
Keaton, how are you feeling?
KEATON: Good.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Looks
like [inaudible]
HOST: All right,
Keaton, good job.
It's nice, light,
fast, easy to swing.
My favorite aspect is how you
had the wood going all the way
through and split up top here.
Your edges are still good.
Everything is tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
now, it's time
to find out how sharp they are.
This is the sharpness
test, the water tube slice.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what your edge
does to those water tubes.
Logan, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Logan,
that's an impressive cut.
Very clean, no jagged
edges on the tubes.
Your weapon, sir, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
All right, Keaton,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
- Yep.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Keaton, let's talk
about your weapon here.
Once again, I have
to mention just
how thin the profile
of your blade is,
making it razor sharp, and
the cuts are very clean.
Overall, sir, it'll cut.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: All
right, bladesmiths,
the weapons tests are complete.
I just need to get
final confirmation
from them about which of you is
our "Forged in Fire" champion.
All right, weapons
tests are complete.
Doug, was one more
effective than the other?
No, they both
performed equally well.
OK, now, let's
talk about weight,
balance, and craftsmanship.
Weight, balance, and
craftsmanship are all
found in one particular weapon.
And that's Keaton's.
HOST: I agree with Doug.
Logan's blade is
really forward heavy.
It's a little harder to control.
WIL WILLIS: All right.
All right, bladesmiths,
the judges have
evaluated your craftsmanship.
You've both done incredible work
here today, but only one of you
can be the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Keaton.
Congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Logan, unfortunately, your
weapon didn't make the cut.
David Baker is going
to tell you why.
Logan, you brought
us a beautiful weapon.
This came down to the
finer details of weight,
and balance, and the
usability of the weapon.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
Yes, sir.
WIL WILLIS: Logan, that is
a highly devastating weapon.
But at this time,
I have to ask you
to please shake our hands, and
then, please, exit the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
LOGAN: I'm happy for Keaton,
but I'm disappointed.
Keaton, that beautifully
crafted and deadly ono
has earned you the title of
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
[applause]
Is that your smiling face?
Because you look like
you're in pain right now.
No, I'm excited.
All right, come on forward
and shake our hands, my friend.
KEATON: I'm a "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I did it.
This experience has been great.
It was definitely a challenge.
The biggest thing I
took away from this
was just work hard, keep
going, no matter what happens.
[music playing]
HOST: The naginata.
[bleep].
All right.
HOST: The naginata
emerged around
1,000 years ago in Japan
as a powerful pole weapon
used by samurai warriors.
Featuring a single edged
slightly curved blade mounted
on a wooden shaft,
this 7 to 8 foot weapon
was ideal for
warding off attacks
from enemies on horseback.
Because it relied on
momentum rather than
upper body strength,
it was an ideal weapon
for female warriors.
The naginata was the weapon
of choice for samurai wives
defending their
homes, and was even
wielded by Seong Menon
in the video game
series "Soul Caliber."
The traditions of
the naginata continue
to be preserved through the
teaching of the martial art,
Atarashii Naginata.
The naginata was a Japanese
weapon known for its long range
cutting ability.
To see how sharp your naginata
is, I will take your weapon,
and I'll attempt to cut
through these tatami mats
and a side of beef.
Theo, you're up first.
You ready?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
Let's do this.
Oh jeez.
All right.
[music playing]
I'll take it.
Yeah, all right.
I just want to point
out that after that test,
your blade has a
slight bend to it.
It almost cut all the way
through one of the tatami mats.
When it came to the side of
beef, it cut cleanly through.
Your blade feels good.
It's got a nice weight
to it, a nice balance.
Overall, your naginata will cut.
Good job.
Thank you.
Joe, you're up next.
You ready?
Oh yeah.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Nice.
Oh, well done, man.
Yeah.
I would say I'm
ahead in the game.
I performed a little bit
better than what Theo's did.
Well Joe, you have
a very sharp blade,
but we now have an issue.
When I cut through the tatami
mat, your handle at the seams
here came apart.
Your handle seam has opened up.
And not only that, it
picked up some cracks
on this side that runs
all the way down here,
and on the other side,
a hairline fracture
that goes down this way.
The seams are big enough
to where I can actually
put my fingernail through them.
That is a critical failure.
And for purposes of
safety, we cannot
continue to test your weapon.
There's nothing?
We can't do nothing?
Bladesmiths, the judges
have determined that there's
no reason to deliberate.
Joe, due to the
catastrophic failure
of your weapon's handle,
you may now leave the arena.
It's not the way
I wanted to win.
I feel like I'm
in a round room
and I'm looking for
a corner to cry in.
It's a pretty tough loss.
Theo, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
that $10,000 prize.
Good job.
[applauding]
You know what I
like about your blade?
The way you reinforced
your handle.
Because the power you
generate with that saved it.
Congratulations.
Thank you, sir.
I am elated to be the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Not the way I wanted to
win, but I'll take it.
I came here the youngest
smallest person and I won.
For the shortest guy, I
certainly came out on top.
[music playing]
The Jumonji Yari.
Originating in the
1500s, the Jumonji Yari
was carried by Japanese
soldiers known as the ashigaru.
These peasant foot
soldiers relied
on the long shafted spear
for its reach and versatility
in combat.
Using the weapon's double edged
cross bars to disarm and pull
mounted samurai
from their horses,
the ashigaru could then employ
the razor sharp central blade
to fatally skewer
the fallen enemy,
and all from a
comfortable distance.
Today, video game
enthusiasts can unleash
the Jumonji Yari's
devastating capabilities
in the game "Shadow Fight II."
The yari, with its long
handle and multi-pronged spear,
makes it a trifecta of points
and edges and a deadly weapon.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your yari and
deliver multiple slashes
and thrust on this pig carcass.
Fouad, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Oh, I'm ready.
[music playing]
Jesus.
All right, Fouad, let's
talk about your yari here.
We felt that it had
very good balance to it.
That on the initial slash right
here, It dug in into flesh.
Then it hit the spine.
The transference of energy hit
a weak spot into your handle
over here.
But it still had a secondary
cut all the way through.
I would consider
your blade a kill.
Thank you.
It was, mine was
beautiful well made.
And some wood grain
just, you know.
Fouad, your weapon suffered
a catastrophic failure.
Now that's bad.
However, you're not out
of this competition yet.
Jacob, your yari still must
perform in this kill test.
Let's see what happens.
Right now, I'm
feeling nauseous.
My heart's pounding in my chest.
My hands are sweaty.
And I just can't wait to see
how it actually goes down.
[music playing]
All right, Jacob.
Let's talk about your yari.
In the initial swing, instead
of being able to cut cleanly
with this part to cut
through, this got in the way
with the angle that it had.
But let's talk about
these particular blades.
They are sharp enough to
penetrate into the pig carcass.
The thrust is really devastating
and very deep into that.
Your handle construction,
it stayed true.
No issues at all.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
My yari held up.
And I'm just-- thank you God.
Well Fouad, the
blades of your yari
were beautifully constructed.
The overall weapon
was very elegant.
However, your shaft
broke in our first test.
And we cannot move
forward in this
competition because that is a
catastrophic weapon failure.
And I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
I was really confident
going into the competition.
I felt like my yari was
going to really perform
a lot better than Jacob's.
And it's just pure
irony all the way down.
Jacob, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applauding]
How do you feel right now?
I feel amazing.
I came here to prove that I can
actually come out here at 19
and compete with
serious knife makers.
Thank you, sir.
Really, I would have liked to
beat Fouad in a different way.
But I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
$10,000?
It's awesome.
[music playing]
HOST: The Japanese katana.
The katana is the
traditional weapon
of the samurai, the noble
class of warriors in feudal
Japan since around 800 AD.
The katana was formed from
hundreds of thin layers
of the purest steel available.
The quicker draw of the sword
was well suited to combat,
where life versus death
depended on the weapon
you carried into battle.
Over the centuries,
the katana has
taken on many
mythical properties
in legend and culture,
from an ability
to slice through other
swords to splitting a hair.
And it is the sword of
choice for characters
in mega-hits like "Kill
Bill" and "The Walking Dead."
To measure how your blades
stand up against flesh,
Doug will cut
through these fish.
Rich, yours is up.
Let's put it to the test.
[music playing]
Nice.
It will cut.
Yes, it will.
It felt good in the slice.
The recovery was
a little heavier,
but it still felt like
it'll give me a close shave.
Good job.
OK, Matt.
You're up next.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
[music playing]
It doesn't cut.
I'm a little confused by that.
I don't know why it didn't cut.
It's got a very
good feel to it.
It's very light.
It's got a very
nice balance to it.
And it'll cut.
Now for the kill test.
In this, we have
a ballistics dummy
that pretty much simulates
the human form, organs,
and tissues.
The katana traditionally
has a razor sharp edge.
That allows me to find the
gaps in between the armor.
I'm going to try that with your
blade to see how well it does.
Rich, you're up first.
[music playing]
Let's take a look at the damage.
The thrust and the slice
went all the way into
the internal organs in here.
And the kill shot went deep,
all the way into the liver.
I think on the kill
test, this will kill.
OK, Matt.
You're up.
[music playing]
Definitely through
the laceration,
he's disemboweled here.
And a nice big puncture in here.
That definitely
will get the liver.
I think it's passed
the kill test.
Thank you.
You both obviously brought
deadly implements of war here.
But now, it's time to
lock and load, gentlemen.
Because for the strength
test, we're leaving the forge
and we're heading
to the gun range.
What?
All right, gentlemen.
This is the final test for the
"Forged in Fire" championship.
It's the strength test.
Your weapons will be
tested on their ability
to split a bullet.
Your swords are going to
be locked into a vise.
Then we're going to fire
a bullet at your blade.
All right, Matt.
You ready?
Break it.
3, 2, 1.
Engage.
[cheering]
Yes!
Matt, your sword
split a bullet.
There's no damage
on the edge at all.
Held up extremely well.
That is a real true sign
of your craftsmanship.
Thank you.
Very well done.
All right.
Rich, you're up next.
When I look at him set the
gun up and get ready to shoot
that blade, there's
a little bit of doubt
in the back of my mind.
Thinking it may
not survive this.
3, 2, 1.
Engage.
Nice!
Oh yeah!
Straight.
Wow.
That is a real split there.
Nice.
I like it.
That blade didn't even move.
It splits the bullet.
I couldn't have been happier.
There's no mark
on the blade at all.
Held up perfectly.
No chipping.
Everything looks great.
Thank you.
Congratulations, gentlemen.
You should be proud of
the work that you've done.
Which only makes the judges'
decision that much harder.
We'll see you back at the forge.
Matt, Rich, in
just five days, you
have both forged elegant
and lethal Japanese katanas.
But in this
competition, there can
only be one winner of $10,000.
Matt, you are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Congratulations.
Good job, dude.
Rich, you did
not make the cut.
I wish you had done a little
bit more finishing work.
You let the handle
get a little bit skinny.
And it was almost the same
proportions on each side.
So I know you ran into
a time constraint.
But it did split a
bullet, and that's
truly something to be proud of.
I feel a little disappointed,
but the better bladesmith won.
Well, Matt, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
You're going to claim
a $10,000 check.
How do you feel?
This is awesome.
Your blade is beautiful.
Not only is it
beautiful, but it's fast.
Cut so cleanly through the fish.
And on the ballistic dummy,
that just disemboweled it
for the kill test.
Great job.
Blade aside, I
was really impressed
with your handle set up.
Symmetrically, it was correct.
We get good control,
good grip on it.
Very nicely done.
This is such a rush.
I want to drive home
and kiss my son.
I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
[music playing]